[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the singular value decomposition one of
my all-time favorite matrix
decompositions the SVD and what I'm
going to tell you about now is this
extremely powerful modification of the
SVD called the randomized SVD okay so
generally speaking we apply the SVD to
high dimensional data in a matrix X
really really high dimensional
measurement data where we think that
there is some low rank or low
dimensional structure some patterns and
dominant patterns that exist in the
columns and in the rows of this data
matrix that we can mine out and reduce
the dimension of this matrix and the
representation and if that structure
does exist if the SVD was a good idea in
the first place then we can often get
away with doing this randomized singular
value decomposition based on emerging
techniques in randomized numerical
linear algebra high dimensional geometry
and random matrix Theory so some
beautiful mathematics has been coming up
over the last couple of decades that is
driving a new paradigm in how we compute
quantities in linear algebra
computational linear algebra is changing
because of this randomized linear
algebra and the randomized SVD so I'm
gonna walk you through this Jupiter
notebook to show you kind of how you
would do this this randomized SVD now
remember if I have high dimensional data
extracting these low dimensional
patterns can be very useful it cuz is
kind of a compression and information
compression but at the same time
computing it might be quite expensive in
terms of CPU time if this is a massive
data matrix and that's what this
randomized SVD is going to help us with
is giving us the same kind of accurate
and efficient representation of the data
but in much less computational time okay
so this is this is all from this this
data book uw comm you can download the
code you can download the examples this
is from our book data-driven science and
engineering and in this code what we're
gonna do is first we're gonna define
this randomized SVD
function okay so basically what you
would normally use the SVD function for
now you can use this randomized SVD and
then we're going to apply it to a high
resolution image to make sure that it
doesn't mess anything up okay so there's
a math version of this lecture the
previous lecture was just kind of the
math of the randomized SVD here's the
code
and so you'll remind yourself that this
randomized SVD on a matrix X you need to
know what your target rank R is how many
columns of U and V and Sigma you want to
pull out
that's our Q is what we call the the
number of power iterations I'll talk
about that in a minute and P is the over
sampling factor so for now you can kind
of forget about Q and P I'll talk about
those in a minute but the basic idea of
the randomized SVD is that you take your
original data matrix X let's let's draw
this actually pictorially your original
data matrix X and you multiply it by a
random projection matrix P so that what
you get out is kind of a tall skinny
matrix Z and this random projection
matrix P could be could have our columns
where R is the target rank that's kind
of the simple version of the story and
with high probability Z will have the
same kind of dominant column SVD as X
it'll have some of the same features in
the column space it'll it'll represent
the column space of X they'll have
similar spans now this over sampling
factor P oftentimes we find that it's
capital P often we find that it's useful
to sample a few more columns of X P more
columns where P is a small number 5 or
10 and we get a better sketch of the
column space of X so that's over
sampling and then what we do is we
compute the QR factorization of Z to get
an orthogonal basis an orthonormal basis
for this column space
that's this QR here very simple then
what we do is we take X and we project
it into that QR that
Subspace to get this Y matrix which is
very very small rank R or R plus P and
then we do the SVD of Y of this Y matrix
and we use that SVD to estimate the SVD
of X to get the U the Sigma and the V of
the original X matrix by computing the
SVD of a really really really small
matrix Y okay that's the basic idea
power iterations would essentially mean
that if if the singular value
distribution of X doesn't decay fast
enough maybe we multiply X by x times X
transpose a few times and that'll make
the singular values look look like they
drop off faster I'll tell you about that
in a minute
but that's what this little code here in
the middle is doing for power iterations
long story short you know SVD is a
one-line Python command randomized SVD
is just a few more lines it's like ten
lines not much more complexity but it's
going to allow us to approximate this
this rank our decomposition much much
faster okay and with very little loss in
accuracy in fact you can get tunable
error bounds as a function of Q and P so
you can select those so that you can get
a specified accuracy in your in your
model so what we're gonna do is we're
going to read in an image of the planet
Jupiter I'm gonna plot the high
resolution image of Jupiter we're going
to compute the deterministic the regular
SVD of rank 400 we're going to plot that
next to it so the rank 400 approximation
using the expensive SVD and then we're
going to compute the same rake 400
approximation using our fast efficient
randomized svv okay so the target rank
is 400 I've kind of pre-selected that I
know that that's enough rows and columns
to get a good representation of Jupiter
we're gonna do one power iteration and
have an over sampling factor of five
we're gonna have five more columns in
our sketch matrix than 400 which is not
an act not that much of an extra costs
we're going to go from a 400 column Z to
a 405 column C and then we're going to
use those SVD approximations to
reconstruct the planet Jupiter and this
is what it looks like so you can
download this code and run it on your
own and kind of zoom in and see what
everything looks like but what you'll
find is that you really can't tell the
difference between these three pictures
so this is the original image this is
the deterministic SVD of rank 400 and
this is the randomized SVD of 400 and in
all of them you can see all of the
little details you can see the the the
great red spot that kind of
kelvin-helmholtz instability behind it
and all of the features so very little
loss of accuracy here but the randomized
SVD is way way faster okay good so the
last thing I want to show you is
illustrating kind of the use of power
iterations again the randomized SVD is
relying on the fact that your singular
values decay really really rapidly so
that you can approximate the dominant
ones and not have them be contaminated
by the low-energy ones but often times
your singular values will look not as
low ranked as you want
they'll decay more slowly than you want
but if you take the matrix x times X
transpose times X they'll decay a little
bit faster and if you take that squared
times X they'll decay a little bit
faster and a little bit faster and so
the exponent here is called the the
number of power iterations this Q and
you get to select Q based on how fast
you want your singular values to decay
that will directly factor into the error
of your approximation of this randomized
SVD now these power iterations are
pretty expensive over sampling not that
expensive power iterations are pretty
expensive because you have to pass
through your big data matrix a couple of
more times every time you do this power
iteration okay and so if your data is
massive like google data facebook data
even doing a single pass through all of
that data might be massively expensive
and so power iterations can be quite
expensive but they do dramatically
improve kind of the error scaling of
this algorithm and so what we're gonna
do here is we're gonna cook up a random
matrix thousand by 100 nature
and so it's singular values will look
kind of like this straight line it's
just a random matrix and what I'm gonna
show you is that by running through
these power iterations one two three
power iterations we're gonna massively
steepen the decay of those singular
values which is going to make our
randomized estimate much much better so
again here's the original deterministic
SVD with with no power iterations that's
just the slope of the singular values
and as you apply even a single power
iteration this red curve has a much much
steeper drop-off in the singular values
and applying additional additional power
iterations q2 q3 q4 you see that you're
driving the slope down so that your
system looks like it's lower rank
because you're you're kind of you're
driving this the singular value spectrum
down okay so there are whole books and
and 50 page papers written on the
randomized SVD this is a deep
interesting topic of current research in
computational linear algebra lots of the
brightest minds in the field are working
on this problem so you know this
10-minute video is about as shallow as
you can get but I just wanted to
introduce you to this concept show you
how easy it is to actually code up and
start using and hopefully get you
excited about actually you know learning
more about this and maybe contributing
to the current state of the art of these
new randomized techniques in linear
algebra okay thank you